und wir springen mal zum endergebnis und
vergleichen dieses video von rebecca
ring mit einem video von luisa crashen
die auch zum schlechtesten make up
artist ihrer stadt gegangen ist
stuttgart schlechtester make up artist
hamburg stuttgart hamburg entweder die
haben in hamburg alle abgesoffen oder
dieses videos möglicherweise fällt
herzlich willkommen sondern video leute
ich kann nur soviel sagen wer man kann
ja schon länger verfolgt er weiß dass
ich ein sehr großer fan von einer
gewissen youtube schon aus deutschland
bin
diese youtube drin hat den namen rebecca
wing freundlich aber ich habe eine
vergangenheit schon ein zwei videos über
sie gemacht weil ich bei ihr immer öfter
so momente habe ich mir einfach denkst
du dir das stört mich irgendwie
persönlich so sehr dass ich das wirklich
schon im video gießen kann nämlich
darüber lustig machen kann und ja was
soll ich sagen ich sei es letztens da
habe auch schon seit wochen oder monaten
nicht mehr über rebecca ring nachgedacht
und da habe ich in meine insta die ems
reingeschaut weil ich mal gucken was
leute wieder schreiben und das schreibt
mir eine zuschauerin namens jana
unterstrich k l lt img reagier unbedingt
auf das video von rebecca wien mit dem
make up artist ja genau das hab ich dann
auch gemacht hier das video angeschaut
und ich kann euch sagen dieses video von
waging mit dem make up artist ist ein
kommentar von mir wert denn es sieht
überraschung große überraschungen von
beckers kanal sehr gepflegt aus das ist
so dem mainboard für dieses video
darüber hinaus ist mir auch so
angekommen dass wir bei kevin scheinbar
über längere zeit einfach video ideen
von alex wie geklaut hat und dann sogar
das wort alex wie in den kommentaren
blockiert hat damit keiner schreiben
kann haye ist von nxp geklaut was auch
schon ziemlich mieser move ist wenn ihr
dazu ein ganzes video von mir haben
wollte zu diesem video coding von nxp
bekkering könnt ihr mir das mal die
kommentare schreiben
aber ja leute es ist wieder soweit es
ist der dritte 6 2009 10 das sind
mini-computer es wirklich zur sache und
ist schon wieder zeit für ein video über
bekkering denn rebecca ring hat wieder
zugeschlagen man hat wieder videos
gefaked let's go das video das das geht
heißt lasse make up beim schlechtesten
make up artist meiner stadt machen hat
eine million aufrufe nach nur einer
woche zieht dafür und sieht so aus
ich bin wieder da mit einem video für
euch und jetzt auch gute laune
ich weiß nämlich nicht wie das ganze
enden wird cool da geht es uns ja gleich
ich habe auch noch gute laune aber auch
ich weiß nicht wo das ganze enden wird
es besonders bemerkenswert weil dieses
video ist leute das muss man wirklich
mal herausstellen dass rebecca wings
eigene zuschauer sie aufgekauft haben
ihre eigenen zuschauern gesagt rebecca
dieses video sieht fake aus wir glauben
nicht dass es echt ist und das ist schon
das ist eine krasse sache bei den
meisten youtube würde das schon bedeuten
okay dass etwas schief gelaufen weil die
eigene community die leute die einen
mögen und regelmäßig schauen einen
autokorso aber decken ist besonders
krasse lübecker ring habt ich glaube da
mit denen ich mich nicht zu weit aus dem
fenster so sehr junge weibliche
zuschauerinnen vielleicht so von
sozusagen mal so 9 bis 14 13 14 würde
ich sagen dass du der schwerpunkt ich
glaube die hinterfragen nicht allzu viel
aber vorweg ging hat sie geschafft dass
selbst die sich also keine beleidigung
an euch wenn ihr wecker hinschaut aber
rebecca hat es geschafft dass sie ihre
zuschauer die ihr sonst sehr treu sind
sicher fragen was zur hölle geht ab zum
beispiel leder an sind bin ich die
einzige die sich nicht vorstellen kann
dass es echt ist 1000 likes sacher
grüttner wie hast du das bitte so filmen
können das ist ein freund von dir oder
so 1306 summerer koran das ist 100
prozent ein freund ich sag s 100 prozent
also man muss an der stelle sagen
bekkering kompliment selbst deine eigene
community kommt ihr langsam auf die
schliche aber ja rebecca will geht das
video in dem sie so einige bewertungen
von diesem make up artist den sie sich
angeblich dann zu sich reingestellt
vorliest
ok also das scheint die erste bewertung
von diesem ominösen make up artist zu
sein und ja wunder er macht nur
hausbesuche bissig sagt in dem video
jetzt sogar mein gott werde ich kann ich
den bei mehr reinlassen kann man den
vertrauen aber neutral betrachtet macht
es die ganze sache natürlich leichter zu
faken wenn man kann sich nur einen
freund zu sich einladen musste bringen
bisschen schminke mit sagt hat man den
schlechtesten make up artist seiner
stadt freundlich aber wenn es eine
auszeichnung für den schlechtesten make
up artist gebe
der eher wie bekommen rebecca ringst am
anfang dieses videos wie gesagt die
bewertung von diesem make up artist for
und schauspielert übertreibt ihre eigene
reaktion darauf schon relativ starkes
gefühl aber es auch okay kann man machen
was wird den job dazu ich habe wie
gesagt das ganze video schon gesehen und
ich denke es ist fake ihre eigenen
zuschauerin denken dass es fake es aber
ich glaube diese wertung die wir am
anfang gesehen diesen widget vielleicht
sind die von irgendeinem anderen echten
make up artist trifft sich wirklich den
schlechtesten make up artistin ihrer
stadt ausgesucht hat sich davon die
bewertung genommen und hat dann aber ein
freund eingeladen den freund gebeten sie
schlecht zu schminken
man weiß es nicht dann als nächstes ruft
sie den make up artist an und vereinbart
einen termin war gleich mal bei diesen
make up artist anrufen scheint irgendwie
ein mann zu sein also ja rufen wir dort
einfach mal an sollen jetzt achtet mal
auf die stimme von diesem make up artist
und die art und weise wie ihr spricht
also den dialekt oder akzent klingt für
mich nämlich so als würde jemand so tun
als käme aus dem anderen land aber kommt
dann einfach aus deutschland und habe
immer deutsch gesprochen
make-up-artist sind geht das heute nach
also gleich zwei sachen sie stellt sich
als rebecca viewing am telefon vor als
würde da nicht jeder normale mensch
nachfragen was wir der nachname wohin
ruin sowie flügel auf englisch und und
ja man hat jetzt gerade schon so einen
kurzen sound bild von diesem
vermeintlichen make up artist gerade so
sagt morgen machen wir termin morgen ich
bin auf keinen fall eine deutsche
spreche ich komme aus dem ausland geht
das weiter nach morgen aber ich mache
nur hausbesuche
das ist einfach also das ist kein das
ist in meinen augen und in meinen ohren
vor allem ist das kein echter akzent das
klingt wirklich wie jemand der einfach
tut als hätte ein akzent
smokey eyes also ok korrigiert mich also
zeigt mir eine person die wirklich so
spricht ich keine ahnung das klingt
nicht wie russisch alt sind das klingt
nicht wie gar nichts das war komisch
also irgendwie können wir mir nicht so
danach der c-liga eine ahnung was mowgli
ijsselmeer sagt gegen die schmuck oder
so an der stelle muss ich auch nochmal
zwei sachen einfügen also erstmal props
an rebecca für die schauspielerische
leistung und so die energie aufzubringen
dass man dann so tut als wäre es echt
und so energiereich reagiert also wäre
es echt das finde ich nicht schlecht
vielleicht spielen da auch die
wahrscheinlich 50.000 euro youtube
einnahmen pro monat eine rolle
vielleicht ja und dann das rating auf
einmal abgeschminkt und der make up
artist kommt vorbei 8 nach und der
grafik klinik
[Musik]
ok ja erst mal steht sie mit einer
kamera da einfach gemacht aber mit einer
kamera in der hand die tür auf was ich
da ich als make up artistin klar als
natürlich filmt die mich jetzt gerade
wie hier reinkommen in ihrer tür ist er
vollkommen klar hier komplett durch ja
ja also das ist so der mailman mein
kritik kommt bei diesem video das sie
einfach permanent filmt während ein
angeblich fremder make up artist in
ihrer wohnung ist so die hatte die
kammer die ganze land also scheinbar sie
die kamera jetzt wird ein stativ
gestellt das sind so vielleicht so
anderthalb meter in einem komplett
freien raum bis zu dem punkt wo der
make-up-artist nicht gefällt niemandem
auf oder ja und jetzt passenderweise hat
der make-up-artist seine eine leichte
blase und muss gerade zufällig auf
toilette in dem moment in dem er gerade
rein kommt was natürlich auch mega
seriös ist wird jeder normale make up
artist auch so machen und erst mal
toilette gehen perfekte zeitpunkt für
rebecca ring um erst mal seine sache
natürlich forsten
[Musik]
also man kann glaube ich sagen so oder
so es für wacker wing mensch der schon
eine gewisse dreistigkeit hat entweder
für den sehr unwahrscheinlichen fall
dass das echt sein soll was ich nicht
ganz ausklammern wäre was ich für sehr
unwahrscheinlich halte ist sie einfach
so dreist und film mit einer fucking
kamera
das equipment von den typen der gerade
rein gekommen ist und falls es fake ist
war sie so dreist das video zu faken und
kein wort darüber zu verlieren das ist
nicht echt ist wirklich nur druck der
stunden später alter was macht der make
up artist der toilette lernt er die
bibel auswendig was braucht was macht er
da so lange klassische make up hat das
kommt erst mal rein und verschwindet
erstmal eine halbe stunde auf toilette
[Musik]
sieger dieses soundeffekte als fucking
adventures oder herr der ringe und java
schock es ist ein wasserfall kasten drin
sie zumindest so ausführlich
die manager des schockiert nachdem er
damit der toilette fertig war ging es
ans mail kapitza werd mir erst mal meine
foundation versucht irgendwie abzumachen
taschen
ok jetzt kommen super make-up technische
sachen ich weiß ich habe einen großteil
weiblicher zuschauer habe ich bin selbst
davon keine ahnung deswegen überspringe
ich das und wir springen mal zum
endergebnis und vergleichen dieses video
von rebecca ring mit einem video von
luisa crashen die auch zum schlechtesten
make up artist ihrer stadt gegangen ist
rebecca ring und glaube ich in hamburg
luisa crashen soweit ich weiß in
stuttgart das video heißt ich geh jetzt
im schlechtesten make up artisten wie
gesagt von luisa crashen ok dann lasst
uns jetzt mal die endergebnisse des
schlechtesten make up artist aus
stuttgart und wahrscheinlich hamburg
vergleichen fangen wir an mit luisa
crashen okay
das ist der schlechteste make up artist
in stuttgart also man kann jetzt davon
halten was man will doch das zu sehr
geschminkt ist oder nicht aber das sieht
immer noch aus wie ein fucking kunstwerk
finde ich das ist schon handwerklich
geil gemacht
alle konturen stimmt der lidschatten
stieg keine ahnung ist cool dann der
highlighter ist irgendwie auch ist auch
ein highlight
also ich weil ich gerne sich die genauen
worte leute verzeiht mir aber das
gesamtbild stimmt so das ist stimmig
dass immer noch gut aus und das ist der
schlechteste in stuttgart vergleichen
wir das war mit rebecca wehling
das hier ist die arbeit des angeblich
schlechtesten make up artists in hamburg
okay das sieht aus wie ein
verkehrsunfall ohne scheiß oder wie
dieser eine potato head aus toy story
aber nicht wie vom professionellen make
up artist gemacht dass selbst das
schlechteste make up artist ist nicht so
schlecht safe mich hier nochmal
stuttgart schlechtester make up artist
hamburg stuttgart hamburg entweder die
haben in hamburg alle sagt gesoffen oder
dieses videos möglicherweise fällt ja
leute das ist das drama the queen hat
scheinen wir mal wieder ein video
gefällt vermutlich mit dem gleichen
typen mit dem sie schon die ganze game
master scheiße gefegt hat und dann davor
die horror kisten im keller gestellt
wurden auch gefällt mit dem gleichen
typen wahrscheinlich sondern jetzt kuba
wieder ein video gefällt eine million
klicks 3000 euro oder wird er war also
ein
millionen klicks 3000 euro für rebecca
wing ist glaube ich nicht unrealistisch
heute also ohne scheiß dann versteht man
vielleicht auch besser warum sie diese
videos faked weil easy money yahoo hh
schon wieder ein gepflegtes video geil
falls euch dieses video gefallen hat
leute würde ich mich sehr freuen wenn
ihr meinen kanal abonniert und ich würde
euch noch eine weisheit mitgeben blaue
banane sagt unter dem video wie viele
kilo hat er rebecca ins gesicht
geklatscht ein like gleich ein kilo und
es sind am ende
7,2 3 7 tonnen make-up genau danach saß
auch für mich aus das war es soweit für
die haut rein ich küsse augen danke fürs
zuschauen
ich mach's gut